where do things stand with you and Jim
right now it makes me sad that after
five years of loving marriage of with
our ups and downs that we could be in a
place that makes me sad
this is intimate knowledge it's a show
about intimate knowledge is the podcast
before we dig into that I see you know
not the three of you get linked up
because this is not three people I knew
knew each other did we know each other
that's a really good question not know I
guess meant to be this was the Train you
know that was serendipitous sort of
designing me right yeah so how did that
come together I've been working on the
show for quite a long time and then we
were looking for the right team and we
went through long lists of people and we
all just hit it off and I think we've
had organic conversations that should
have been recording since our very first
meeting well the ones that have been
recorded have been pretty wild
I did not expect to see some headlines
already with like Meghan King Edmonds
and circumcision but it seems like
you've just hit the ground running with
this thing talking about that name
intimate knowledge and what it means and
what the goals are for this group yeah
well title is so important and you know
originally we're gonna have the word sex
in the title and that seemed a little
bit too in-your-face for me so we wanted
to bring to life this dialogue about
intimacy which covers so many different
things and it's a conversation that
needs to happen amongst women and it's
not a show just for women it's a show
for everybody but unpacking everything
from romance to love sex connection
heartache who we are who we are as women
and to build ourselves up and create
more confidence within ourselves and our
listeners it's also a conversation and
content that my mom would could listen
to and I would listen to it with her
with no shame so this isn't about an
x-rated conversation this is opening up
the dialogue in
area of conversation I think I would
listen with my mom with a little shame
oh you would
I'm like yes you know what I have been
going through tumultuous time in my
personal life I found out yesterday that
my ex is allegedly having an affair or
seeing somebody
oh you back up a little bit we had just
gotten married and trying to have fun
and he wanted to have a threesome we
decided to have a threesome of
consensual adult decision with a friend
of mine I felt very comfortable with her
so they are in Cabo right now
this girl who I thought was my friend Oh
who I I cast aside my uncomfortability
with the threesome because I was fun I
wanted to do things for my husband
[Music]
do you think maven has straight affair
the whole time for a year I don't know I
think they probably had sex more than
one time I want to dial in on you for a
second Meghan because your life is
different from we were just chatting
about five years ago we did our first
interview my first interview with E to
you and yours life's different from five
years ago life's different from three
months ago how are you doing I'm good I
feel happy about where my life is going
in the future and what the future holds
so I'm just really like looking at that
silver lining and trying to be healthy
about it and focus on my kids we've all
been reading and keeping up with and
you've been so open about everything you
were going through where do things stand
with you and Jim right now what is the
status how do you define that
relationship um it's I think it could be
better
it makes me sad that after from five
years of loving marriage of with our ups
and downs that we could be in a place
that makes me sad but I'm hopeful for
for I don't know
communication in the future yeah we'll
just we'll just keep it like that it
sounds like the podcast records here in
LA or iheart space are you living in LA
now well I have a place in LA because of
my son is getting treatment here therapy
in LA for for his his brain trauma that
he has but I'm not living living here
but I'm not not living here
how is co-parenting working well it's so
I've had the kids with me um my son is
in therapy here for three weeks it's an
intensive therapy and so the kids have
been with me every day for the three
weeks so co-parenting could improve so
everything's kind of in a it's working
for it needs to but it could get better
okay sure I'll take that phrase go for
it good that's a working divorce it's
probably the most important and most
challenging part and you know there's
good seasons and challenging seasons and
you learn and you know strive to take
the high road and raise your children
together and you know deal with all of
the uncertainties that go along with it
how do you have those conversations with
the kids I mean you have your boys are
so so little but like how aware is a
Aspen of what's happening she's pretty
aware it's funny she like she
understands already that there's mommy's
house and daddys house and she'll talk
about it and somebody it was a babies
that are asked me if I was married and
asking who just turned 3 of November
said no mommy's not married so stuff
like that it's so interesting somebody
got married in a Disney way I think
that's how she knows what it is and she
understood that mommy wasn't married so
they're just little balls of energy like
they absorb whatever is around them and
and Jim was just around for a few days
and they were
very irritable children but they also
had to see their mom and dad interact
and that is not a place where that makes
me feel good and so I saged my whole
house afterward we can't hide from our
children of course and separation is for
everyone not just the couple it's your
family and serve close friends is your
you know immediate and extended family
and the children I mean everybody goes
through the breakup and so I think
that's a really important lesson for
everybody everybody needs to adjust yeah
you know friends and family as well big
change have you been able to lean on her
through all this and have you been able
to impart some wisdom well I hope so but
you know it's a process
it might happened a little bit longer
ago right so I'm coming out on the other
side now and almost divorced but what a
process and you know you have such great
respect for you know your willingness to
have open conversations because I don't
know that I could have done it a year
ago you know it takes time to heal and
to understand and you have to meet
yourself with compassion that's one of
the things I love about this show is
that we have an opportunity to educate
women and it's not that our way is the
right way but we're just having a
conversation because so many people
around the world are going through
similar things and different
circumstance though you know every every
circumstance is different so yeah you
can relate to one another but ultimately
you only know what's best for yourself
that's right I can handle a baby and
women who act like women Megan you are
used to being so open and honest because
you shared your life for years on
reality TV would you ever go back and do
that again yeah I would I loved it I had
a great experience because it you know
the fans want to see detective Meghan
King Edmonds back on TV
that would be great I just really would
love it I had a great experience on the
housewives um I it's not something I'm
dying to do but I would definitely
wouldn't say no I have a really thick
skin too I think
and so for people to come at me with
insults and and like it doesn't bother
me as much I just am Who I am like take
it or leave it I don't care really what
you have to say I'm not trying to hurt
anybody in the process but yeah I
totally do it again and Brooke when I
was sitting here thinking I was like
she's ever been offered housewives or
anyone's approached her about that
because you seem like you might be built
for it
right I know I the conversation has come
up quite a lot and I have so many
friends you know that has done the show
and have been thrilled and it's worked
out incredible for them I never say
never you know the dynamic of my family
has changed so much there were plenty of
times in my life where I wouldn't have
exposed my four children and I don't
know that my ex would have been even
open to that but now that now that I get
to make all my own decisions like a bona
fide bro now you know you never know I
know isn't that an amazing question
what's so interesting is Lila you're the
married lady like she in my opinion you
have such a sexy sensual healthy
relationship that we all long for right
lucky lady a you two are on the market
well it looks like you maybe you're a
little off the market what's there's a
man on your Instagram no Izzy what's the
deal I mean how serious is it and it's
where you going it's serious I don't
know where it's going so I'm I'm working
to sort of partner up with uncertainty
and just enjoy what is right now I like
that free is partner up with uncertainty
that's a challenge I've worked really
hard to get to that space but he's
amazing and loving and kind and sexy and
sweet and fun and I'm really really
happy right now and we're enjoying each
other's company and it's growing and it
feels right and I think like like the
right kind of love just feels easy it's
easy just close yeah ready to get back
out
focusing on my kids but um like if an
opportunity were to like smack me in the
face like I'm not gonna just say no
right but I don't know we'll see what's
on day at a time one day time okay
maybe what are the three top things that
are kind of the checkmark for the slap
in the face like it was like if three
boxes were checked it's a you make them
like fireworks at sunset on the beach
like that with the sign that would do a
physical sign it wouldn't help to
actually it's not me in the bright no I
wasn't meaning more like has a job
that's a good start thank you I'm gonna
add that we are about to record we've
said in that very first episode that
nothing is off-limits is that really the
case there's no where you're not willing
to go on this thing you know it's it's
um there's a fine line I mean I'm
committed to this open dialogue and a
very honest and transparent conversation
but I also have four children and I'm
raising three daughters and I like to
respect the intimacy of my relationships
and things have to remain sacred so
there's an element of respect and
honesty but we're sharing our
experiences for the right reasons we're
figuring it out listening to these in
blind like their conversations that I
did not expect to hear sitting at my
desk at work so I'm like okay this is
interesting
good question I guess we don't know
either
so are you most excited for for what's
upcoming and for the fans and new
listeners to get into with you guys I'm
ready to do some deep dives we did some
glossing over of topics and we cast a
wide net about is what we're going to be
doing but doing some deep dives into
that as an intimacy expert what's the
topic you're most excited to dive into
I'm what I'm most interested in is
connecting women with their deepest
desires so the more that we can have
this dialogue and help women connect to
that that's what I want are you gonna be
okay with that
like Lila's totally my therapist Brooks
totally my therapist so I just listen
I'm there to learn and absorb so this is
great for me it's there it's a learning
opportunity for everyone it truly is and
you know even tacking on to that it's
about loving yourself and really tapping
into that and not necessarily bout
falling in love but you know falling in
love with yourself as well and
discovering all of the amazing things
that we all possess and sort of
celebrating that right well I think
there's no better message to leave it on
right
[Music]